- In a few moments, the room will go dark,
the screen will light up,
and we will watch just a
few of the brilliant moments
of the career of a great actor,
a great star who makes
all the rest of us actors
proud to be actors.
This is Liv Ullmann.
(audience applauds)
Most of us would be happy to sit back
and watch nothing but her film
clips for the next two hours,
but we have other matters to attend to.
So let me offer up the
much shorter Lithgow list
of reasons why Liv so abundantly
deserves tonight's tribute.
First there is Liv's legendary history
as the collaborator and muse
of the iconic Ingmar Bergman.
(audience applauds)
She appeared in 10 Bergman films,
among them "Persona,"
"Cries and Whispers,"
"Face to Face," and "Autumn Sonata."
For those few who claim she
would never have been called
one of our greatest actors
without Ingmar Bergman,
I would answer Bergman would
probably never have been called
one of our greatest filmmakers
without Liv Ullmann.
(audience applauds)
After a long career creating
a film legacy second to none,
Liv turned her attention to directing.
She embraced this new role
with a joy and passion,
an early pioneer in the struggle
to right the imbalance
between men and women in film,
guiding and mentoring the likes
of Jessica Chastain in "Miss Julie,"
and Cate Blanchett in her
definitive stage performance
as Blanche DuBois in "A
Streetcar Named Desire."
(audience applauds)
For those of you from Beverly Hills,
a streetcar is a
multi-passenger vehicle on rails
(audience laughs)
typically operated on city streets.
Now the great power of Liv's
achievements as an actor
and as a director arises
from her boundless capacity for empathy.
But yet another demonstration
of that empathy is her advocacy
dating back to the 1970s
on behalf of refugees.
Tirelessly working with
such organizations as UNICEF
and the International Rescue Committee,
Liv has heightened awareness of the plight
of refugees all over the world,
and raised millions of
dollars for their relief.
Her commitment to the refugee
issue shines especially bright
at this deeply troubling
historical moment.
In this cause, she has
never ceased to follow
the concise rule she
has forged for herself:
Don't turn away.
It's a phrase that could be used
with equal accuracy to describe
the profound artistry of Liv Ullmann.
Tonight is your moment of course, Liv,
but let me share my own
memory of her special magic.
Years ago, I acted with her on Broadway
in Eugene O'Neill's "Anna Christie."
Liv played the title character of Anna,
a sad prostitute hungry for redemption.
The show was directed
by the brilliant, volcanic Jose Quintero.
One day halfway through rehearsals,
I watched Jose take Liv
into the heart of darkness,
invoking for her the desperation
and degradation of a life of prostitution
by calling on his own childhood memories
of dockside prostitutes in Panama City.
I was not in the scene they
were rehearsing that day.
I was just sitting and watching them work,
but under Jose's spell,
I saw Liv fearlessly absorb, internalize,
and bring to life the pain
and loss of a broken woman
far outside her own experience.
It was a moment of aching empathy
which she managed to sustain
for the next six months of performance.
I've seen a lot of great acting in my day,
but I've never seen anything like that.
But don't take my word for it.
Take a moment to watch this
remarkable woman at work.
I promise you one thing:
You won't turn away.